So we have to find the mean and standard deviation of the sampling
distribution. Sorry I'm making you calculate this again even though you did it
in the previous lesson. I just want to make sure that you continue to get
enough practice doing this. So for the sampling distribution, where we take all
samples of size 20, because in this case our sample consisted of 20 students.
We have that the mean is the same as the population mean, and the standard
error, which is the standard deviation of the sampling distribution, is the
population standard deviation, divided by the square root of the sample size.
So this is about 0.14. So then this means that this sample mean has a z score
equal to 7.13 minus the mean 7.5 divided by 0.14. If you put the more exact
values into your calculator, then you'll get a more precise z score rather than
using the rounded standard error. So we get about negative 2.59. If we look at
the distribution of sample means and here is 7.5 the population mean and the
mean of sample means negative 2.59 is way over here, so what does this mean.